hello everyone.welcome we are at MIT the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology we
are here with dr. luis perez Bravo all
right thank you for joining us thank you
for having me we appreciate it so much
Luis is a PhD in computer science and AI
he is the author of innovating a Dewar's
manifesto which we are gonna unpack in
great detail very excited for that and
also the faculty director of the MIT
innovation teams program for the last 10
years combining with the School of
Engineering School of Management
business so this is gonna be good to
unpack let's let's dive right into this
maybe tell us a little bit about how
exactly did you end up studying all
these different degrees you have some
physics you have some AI of this
biochemistry right how did you how did
you kind of do all these different
degrees that led you into being such a
good asset for the i-team's weed here
yeah well it's it's hard to actually
answer that question in kind said I
would give you a story today that
probably doesn't resemble the way I made
those decisions I've always been really
interested where I thought I was really
interested in Chemical Engineering which
is how he started but I felt I was
missing math so I went for AI then I
thought that was fizzing missing physics
so I stopped my AI training to go for
physics half the way through the process
I felt that that what I really wanted to
do was get technology to places so then
I studied business and all I can say now
is that none of them had everything I
needed so I needed to get them all yeah
I wish they will have another path but
that's the path that emerged along the
way I really enjoy that answer cuz you
you there's so much knowledge that
exists and it's very humbling to say
I'll never get all of it but what I will
do is I will strategically acquire the
parts that I think maximize myself
bringing value to the world and helping
others bring value to the world you see
that that's actually the way I think on
and I tell my students you know after
probably too many degrees I figured
that there was no way I was ever going
to be ready for what I needed to do next
the stories have been funnier because I
finished Chemical Engineering I joined a
group that we started their company for
self on location that required AI and in
telecommunications which I was killed
prepared for so I had to study it as I
went then I decided to go into the AI
thing after the fact and did the PD
after starting a company and it's been
quite successful company and so what I
finally learned is that I guess I'm
doomed to be interested in projects I
may not be that prepared for no matter
how many degrees I have and so I had to
start to learn on my own and I think
that's actually even easier today you do
because of what many people do then it
was when I started you know internet was
infancy I was a heavy consumer of it but
encyclopedia and now you can actually it
almost invites from the different
approach if you really want to solve
problems in the world there is another
way of doing it today I'm not saying you
shouldn't study you should definitely do
that if that's what you want to do but
you have so many more options that you
are not limited by whatever your study
yeah and that's actually phenomenal and
the process of learning is not limited
to a school you know the the school is
your habit it's your desire for learning
and so in order for you to be a lifelong
learner it's about waking up every day
and saying that I want to keep learning
I want to keep growing and I don't want
to just stop after school okay but it's
it's a it's also been great there's ways
we teach now at MIT I do that every
semester that we could not have done
before all these things were available
on the internet yeah so I find that even
this access to all this information has
helped us create new ways to introduce
pedagogy that were really hard into this
before yeah
like learning by doing things mastery
experiences that we can set up as
through educational experiences much
better now than before another part of
this was accessible you saw so much will
work right yeah
because that's such a you're right about
making sure that we address this point
because the last even couple decades pre
pre explosion of knowledge available on
the internet was it was much more
difficult to acquire knowledge we have
to spend more time walking to library
and finding the right books you weren't
able to just click open a video and just
get it streamed right to you right away
it's very important to remember that now
we have all of it at our fingertips and
it's actually changing the minds of the
kids that are growing up into the world
and how they're able to access
information what they're able to learn
as such young ages but in many cases
it's also giving them the ability to
waste their time with technology as well
which is a whole separate conversation
about what's called separate
conversation what is good what is not as
good for time investment okay so
innovation in the Dewar's manifesto so
this was how long ago was this written
so I started to write it in about 2015 I
get that right if i remember that
correctly i finished the manuscript in
2016 early 2016 and you know there's
what we were talking about how much you
learn as you're going yeah I thought
that was it it turns out it wasn't it
was the beginning so then there were
lots of the conversation start to think
about conveying this to people how to
think how to edit it how to insert
illustrations that that would reflect
the nature of the work and for for
visual learners in addition to kind of
text learners then all the thinking
about how to promote the book not just
really did a really good job actually in
it for the visual learners as well that
was really well done that you know the
story of that is is phenomenal so when I
first proposed the book to the MIT press
I told them you know I want to have a
book that's seriously academic in the
sense that it has the quality seal but
can be read by anyone they looked at me
and saying yeah that's not going to
happen but it's okay
then I told them and I also want to have
for every chapter a visual description a
summary of the chapter it's visual
that's actually artistic something you
actually would enjoy looking at and that
if you're a visual learner you'll get
what I'm getting heading that and they
looked at me and said okay you know you
get as the book that will be fine but
you know they were very much will not
throw it out immediately
I passed a little review processes we
started the book and as the book came to
an end I realized I was coming to an end
I realized I had not yet figured out
what I was going through with the
illustrations so I had never met an
illustrator or maybe I had but I didn't
know and so I didn't know what to do and
I'm not particularly good at drawing I
have lots of imagination I just don't
know how to draw so there was stuck and
one thing led to another
I met this phenomenal sculpture here in
Cambridge Nick
you would see his name in death inside
the book and was just a phenomenal
artist and we discussed and he said you
know what I would like to draw this for
you I told him I was singing it a bit of
a mixture of Esther and and I told him
in artists terms and he at the end of
the day he told me you know what I get
it why didn't you tell me how you
imagined a chapter and I'll draw it we
had this phenomenal collaboration in
which what you see is the way I imagine
each chapter drawn beautiful in ways I
would have never even be able to come
close to it phenomenal project but it's
a testament to how this organically grew
and it became a massive learning process
for me I had no clue that writing about
was anything close to these there's you
know throughout you have these
illustrations that really help people my
my favorite or one of our favorites
mechanized favorites was and then the
quotes are really great you put that was
an idea for the from the MIT press
so these one of our favorites yes yeah
it is it's such a good one yes tell us
what it means to you well you know the
thing about the you see illustrations is
that you could argue that the book is
either written in the illustrations and
then expanded on the chapters or the
other way around
uh-huh larger how you think about it the
basic idea of what I wanted to convey
and what Nick and I discussed about this
well you know you everybody wants to be
very strategic and about these and so I
wanted just to really depict an idea
that you know well what do you see bread
really is like this chapter gives
meaning to this particular situation
that's just mostly a chessboard that's
broken right with fretting stuff on one
end and comfortable thing on the other
mm-hmm and that's about it and that's
the way we thought about it because yeah
now I could tell you why each of these
things are there yeah but then that
makes it boring you see what I mean like
it's it's yeah I imagine it yeah
visual learners don't need me to
decades them on every single particular
piece and the people that don't
appreciate the visual aspect for the
learning piece they have the text those
two things coming together correct and
and that's the trick of it if I had
tried to do the traditional traditional
business or management books would try
to have diagrams but that's kind of like
almost programming my reader right a
diagram is an algorithm so I'm actually
programming the reader I do that I will
need to choose and it I could have done
a diagram maybe I'll write another book
with the diagrams in it but and that was
not the intent he's a little more
open-ended for them to interpret the
visualizations along with the text so
that's a really good point that as you
write think about the ways that your
writing can be perceived and realized
fully realized visually as well so
people are learning both through the
writing through the visual and then even
like you said with MIT press they took
these these Keys phrases out and they
put them in also in these cool boxes
along the way which was again really
good for people to rephrase the in their
head again and again the the important
pieces of content so okay so give us the
thesis so the Dewar's manifesto
well the thesis you can start innovating
anytime anywhere with whatever you have
that's about it and and the second part
of that is that all it takes is to be
thinking about trying to solve a real
problem and of course there is no way
you can figure out what the real problem
is today because you haven't started so
that's something you're going to learn
along the way but the key point is that
you cannot possibly know today so any
gas or prediction you make it's just a
guess you can change it you should
change it and you use you should use
your hands to change that what you have
most important though you should avoid
thinking that you have the next
disruptive idea because you cannot
possibly know that
disruptive ideas do not are not judged
by their beginnings they're judged by
their ends so then all you're doing is
guessing and you know there are so many
examples of ideas that we now take for
granted that started out in
inconsequential ways actually the first
two chapters are all to show you you
know kind of written in a variant I hope
entertaining way at least I think so
examples that if you look at them from
the very beginning you can realize that
all these disruptive thing is hindsight
yes yeah once you're done oh yeah that
was they dropped it yeah but of course
by then you're done or someone else is
done right these early stages it it
usually actually hurts more to be
thinking to yourself that all this is
gonna be disrupted as a unicorn this is
so no you the daily operations are you
for it to integra mentally make your
value and more value with your idea yeah
that that's the thing we're saying that
because one of the aspects of the book
is that if you think about what you have
to do then you we need to realize that
disruptive or not you're going to go to
tomorrow from today mm-hmm that's
incremental so what you need to
understand how to do is what you do day
after day exactly it's not a matter of
how many resources you have or how much
money you have or whether you have to do
a small experiment or notice that you
need to have continuity day today that's
the very definition of incremental so no
matter how your idea disrupts the world
eventually somehow some many years after
the fact
today and tomorrow what you need to
understand is what to do or an
incremental basis yeah and that's the
main thesis my my idea what I've
discovered over research and teaching
and doing it myself in my own ventures
is that if you adopt this mentality a
lot of things that seem to be obvious
when told in hindsight actually hard to
implement
for instance that coulda stand I'll tell
you with my book in the first meeting I
had with the MIT press they asked me who
is my audience of my book I don't know I
said what do you mean you don't know how
many done your market I said yeah sure
but can I talk ass yeah right so well
who's your user they would ask me is it
me that's far cuz I'm the only one
looking at the book maybe you guys
because you're also looking at it with
me but beyond that we can guess a lot of
things but I think we should write it
for the it's substance and the problem
we want to solve not so much for who we
can tactically place it to yeah we can
sort those things out afterwards as well
and of course some people will not like
it then some people will like it but if
I create an honest product and a genuine
one more people will like it from a
bunch of backgrounds and if I try to
tactically targeted target some
particular collectors based on some
profiling yeah so that turns out that
when you're actually writing it it's
really hard to write for those imaginary
users so the standard advice focus on
your users is really hard to implement
on a date they've all such a substance
but if you understand the problem or the
nature of um you want to solve
of course you'll get a lot of feedback
from a lot of people right but just
because there are people and they have
depth you know they're thinking not
because their profile users and so a lot
of things that seem very reasonable and
they are very reasonable from the design
world do not map that well to day-to-day
operations when you're truly trying to
address a problem they will eventually
once you actually know who your users
are yeah
but it takes some discovery to get there
and you cannot anticipate that
predicting these things is actually
risky in many ways i I really let's
let's structure this out and then we'll
get to the the next point
I love the whole notion of having these
these times when we when we're observing
the world around us and then we realize
that there's something about the world
around us that we really want to change
and make it better and then with that we
might write it down what we want to
change and how we want to change it and
then we want to revisit it later we want
to maybe take out a either a design tool
on the computer or a pen and paper and
we want to actually start playing around
with how we want to change it how we
want to build it and maybe ask a couple
other people what their thoughts are
about it what do you need to do
incrementally the next day with this
design do you need to actually order a
couple parts into your house
to try and build this up what's the next
step do you need to go show it to
somebody at a business that might want
to buy the the product or value that
you're trying to bring to them and so
this whole and innovating incrementally
is so important these incremental
innovation I love that aspect of it and
I also just I do agree with you about
the words creativity and
entrepreneurship and how they're very
very frequently used today but really
it's usually only looking back do we say
that oh that was this book was very
creative because it was in your head
before and then people were able to
judge it afterward and say oh it was
really creative it is creative but this
kind of leads us to the to the next step
to the next part of the conversation
which is that the the act of taking this
understanding of our world and trying to
solve a problem about it that's kind of
another one of the thesis --is that's
baked into the book is that it has to be
solving a real-world problem and you
want a prototype Ahn's how to solve the
problem so yeah so that's one of you the
the main thesis of book is that the
things that you at some point you call
innovation and now you take for granted
the number of those things is ginormous
right and so there's literally your
entire day is composed of things that
you take for granted that at some point
changed the world dramatically and
before that they looked incremental
right and so Allah I give lots of
examples about that in the book I talk
about the laser how it starts mostly as
a side project in an industrial lab the
first laser in existence and now you
can't live without the laser you don't
even know it's there but your entire
life the internet you know how the
things you can get manufactured today
depend on the existence of lasers so you
may not have one yourself but you depend
on maybe a hundred everyday now the
other example I love and I love these
examples because they they they reveal
what you aspire to do right well despite
the completion at the end of your road
forget how big the market forget those
things from those are instruments or
means to an end but you know at the end
of the day you want to change the world
because you've solved the problem you
don't know what the problem was
beforehand you sort of discover that
your way and my favorite example is is
that this is not in the book actually
but I use a lot in classes is the
washing machine first because I love it
because no one would have expected me to
say washing machine right now but the
other reason why I love it is because
take it out it's assumed someone bans it
and then what immediately happens is
that something you took for granted that
we're still solving a real problem an
enabling society to go further is Conner
and your entire time structure of your
time changes hotels are cannot clean
told in the same way or any plenty more
employees to do the same amount of work
you need to have detergents that are
different detergents and companies that
are based on the fact that washing
machines exist will lose their profit
immediately the level of cleanliness in
the world will go down maybe this is
women so the world which will change yes
I claim that you we might actually go
back a hundred years so that's why the
washing machine was a phenomenal
innovation it's because it changed us so
that we could go beyond yeah it's not
the product the best part I'm more into
exact other innovations and go further
education would be so much harder yeah
if you had to have that extra time right
or you had to reserve that extra time
so it's important to see that because
that's what you aspire to do right so
now why do we know that this was an
innovation because if you take it out
all the problems become obvious those
were not obvious as promised were just a
matter of life yeah hundred years ago
200 years ago whenever before these
things became sort of adopted and so
your job when you're on the other end
without the hindsight is well you know
there's got to be a problem somewhere
here but now now at best I see a hunch
right you don't know that washing
machine will solve the problems you
don't know what the problems are you may
have the hand so let's start by
prototype
that hunch of a problem not the product
yeah right otherwise you can just
obsessed with just the product then you
forget that you wanted to solve a
problem yeah yes as you try to product
that you order parts you write it down
you need to think no three things right
it's very simple actually you need to
know when you're done of course you will
not get that right away but that's what
you need to work on is if an alien
species were to land here and give you
death it that actually solves the
problem would you even know that thing
actually solves the problem most likely
no to same as if I give you the solution
to a problem you don't understand you
may not even know if it's actually a
solution math or so on the second thing
you need to know is that you need to
actually be able to recognize what the
actual problem is all the exercise we
just did with the machine
the washing machine allowed us to see
how big and many fold the problem was we
can recognize what the problem would be
if you remove this and I'm sure we
didn't even cover half the surface of
the actual true problem but this we can
understand what people can accomplish
now that that problem has been removed
yeah that's the second thing and the
last thing is that you can imagine 50
other ways you could have solved it
because problems are beautiful because I
have plenty of solutions yeah so it's
not about the one product is that
because we were focusing on a problem
there are probably plenty other products
you could build either in parallel
either you start with one and you
realize that it you should more of your
efforts and go to another version of the
problem that solved with a slightly
different way and so it's not about one
solution or one products that you could
probably do three or four or five and so
just that all those things you can
actually get some parts right download
the your first answers to those things
try to build them and demonstrate to
yourself that's actually a problem and
talk to someone so that you can see how
in their perspective what you just
present as a problem is actually a
different problem and before you know it
you'll have something you can actually
go to people and describe to them that
you can solve and then that at the end
you get the product not at the beginning
yeah at the end and so you should use
no-ball in today's it's not the
alternative is the following have a
product idea
hope for the best and start to try to
place it dad might well sometimes works
but you need to have a lot of clarity
about the product and a desire to invest
a lot of time in just that product yeah
because it takes a long time for
companies or for endeavors to actually
accrue the amount of people they need
and the adoption to show that they do
indeed have a problem they have to have
some sort of utility still otherwise the
product won't do well it has to have a
utility and yeah with solving a problem
you automatically have utility we're
solving a problem well you're starting
their understanding with the utility and
you're trying to put up with that you do
these and make it tangible and the more
tangible you make it the more ideas for
potential products you have and the more
and this is the critical piece the more
you'll be able to reuse ideas from one
domain to the next domain that reusing
is what gives you then economies of a
scale and all those beautiful words that
can only be understood once you've done
them I was thinking about this while
you're talking about it because when the
washing machine was first around well
when humans were washing humans were
maybe using their arms or their legs and
spinning clothes around and then we had
the electricity that was doing that part
for us it was top-loading then it became
this whole front-loading one and you
just pour detergent on the top and now
there's a there's a companion to service
on your phone or on their sensors inside
that will tell if it's delicates or
whatever so there is so many more
iterations of this advancement now that
have happened you use less water now
useless detergent now detergent is
completely environmentally friendly now
totally biodegradable totally safe to
eat whatever so there's always
iterations now that ever occurred and
then you maybe take these iterations
that have occurred across the laundry
machine the washing machine and then you
bring them to another unique industry
that they're not gonna be the exact same
ones but they're gonna be maybe starting
with the same principle of oh how do we
give people more time how do I solve a
problem that gives people more time and
then from there then I'm already
starting to see the world differently
for example we always talk about this on
the show now
sometimes talk about commuting commuting
is a huge time-suck sometimes it's a
half hour an hour each way to just
commute every day so why didn't we
figure out as soon as possible or even
in civilizational design we were first
starting how to keep work closer to our
homes so that we didn't need to go do
this crazy whole commuting and now we're
moving towards the location agnosticism
with a RvR and all these other
technologies I'm just I'm in love with
the idea of starting with a problem and
wanting to prototype on a problem and a
lot of this channel was the problem of
this missing piece of not enough
highlighting entrepreneurs highlighting
innovators highlighting scientists
highlighting educators technologists
people that are really learning what's
brand new and then trying to bring it to
the world and amplify their voice and so
because we had this missing piece and it
wasn't being done on this cool Daily
Show in San Francisco these live events
etc we knew that we we love doing this
and we want to bring it to more people
and then the value could then the value
is you know tested by the amount of
people that watch the amount of
discoveries you gain the amount of
patrons we gain etc without the value in
your case and back to to your to your
comment about you know how to
washing-machine
what you learn with a washing machine
then can help you in a bunch of other
areas yes so the true value of what
you're building now is that you know
have a new set of parts that you've just
built to solve the first version of the
problem you could actually see but in
the washing machine example for instance
or in the Amazon mean you could even
talk about the way the history of how
Amazon Web Services started right it
starts with something they have and they
feel there is another run they can solve
but the first version of that problem
the first kind of tangible demonstration
can be done of a things they already
have right and then all of a sudden
website Amazon Web Services comes in
it's a enormous success for
but the trick is that it starts with
what you have so as you go down this
path today you perceive the problem to
be as you explained you know there is a
missing we are not highlighting enough
people that have this this different
vantage point rather scientists
innovators entrepreneurs and so on and
that's the hunch that got you started
right 10 years down the road when you
are a massively successful right and I'm
calling you to see if we can interview
me again the you look back into this and
say no well yeah that's how we started
but we always started the vision was
this larger thing because to you if we
look as though it never truly changed at
the way you described it early on was
the way just described it today it
doesn't matter because all you're
building today can get you there because
everything that you've built videos the
channel the audience the patrons all of
that is part of a larger thing that will
eventually solve this big problem right
or not yes yes and if it doesn't and
like you said earlier there's a bunch of
different ways to target the baculum and
we're targeting it from a different way
to try and inspire kids children to care
more about these different subjects and
even adults to teach the kids these
different subjects and then there's so
many other ways to get children like
there's the projects where the kids go
and they start learning how to play with
gardens and the learning how to grow
their own food and what that means and
then there's all the projects of the
kids that are able to go out into the
forest so to be able to play with with
with augmented technologies are going to
rely technology so there's so many new
ways now to target these problems and to
solve them I want to make sure that we
make sure to highlight this point that
you mentioned because it really really
resonates with me this washing machine
example and how if it goes away all of
the things that you listed would happen
that there would be the massive like
what would hotels be doing how would you
spend your time you would have to wash
clothes for hours every single week
instead of just throwing it in the
machine and leaving it and then you
would more potentially dirtier people
you'd wear clothes longer more does
you list all these things and I think
they really start ticking away in your
head like no the washing machines
actually one of the most important
inventions they gave us so much more
time and if we didn't have it we go back
so now the question becomes in my head
is are you are we are we all working on
things that if they were to disappear
would send civilization back a couple
decades it's an excellent point so
there's the wit to look at it so first
of all don't stress out right you know
because when the washing machines
started those problems that we now
perceive to be as ginormous because we
have now a new lifestyle yeah we're just
standard of living okay so the
disruption is what caused us to see the
problem but the disruption happened
afterwards so your idea does not need to
start disruptive yeah
and that's important because it means
like they're the less you obsess with
that how these rubs if I will be the
more you can actually focus on what
problems can I solve right and the more
you can focus on what things we actually
have available to me to start to make
this as tangible as I possibly can right
and that's critically important what to
understand what you have what you need
to learn what you don't know and then
try to make it real if you can make it
real and accept that as a basic fact
that you are not that interested in that
after all and then move on to the next
time and and that's it so it's it's look
at it that way now the other way to look
at this is that we focus on problems the
problems are not obvious you need to
learn them we don't focus on products
and I think that one way to understand
the difference between those two is by
piggybacking of the obsession with
artificial intelligence today and use
where I'm heading with this but if you
read the press and you were to replace
artificial intelligence with alien
species in every single place our
division versions appears in the article
you would see that the actual coverage
kind of matches we're describing a
product that does not exist but it's
threatening because of the attributes it
has we're already calling it disruptive
and it really feels like a new species
it going to come to invade no one is
asking the actual really interesting
which is look at that we have all these
things we know how to do with computers
that were invented in the quest for
artificial intelligence we have not
found intelligence yet so don't worry
we're not there right but each of these
things are now part she could use to
actually solve a real problem and that's
true and everyone I know that has made
an event in the world with AI has done
it because they've actually solve
problems using those tools yes
whether you argue whether that's actual
really AI or not a guy generalized
whether we should change the definition
of AI which I think we should that's a
separate thing the important is that you
can solve problems with it there's more
of us talked about hey you know what
yeah yeah it's cool movies are great I
love Jarvis ex machina not so much but
let's figure out the way we'll make this
useful for us in ways that's where you
start to hit the companies that are
really bringing value with let's just
call them computational technologies or
advanced computational technology that
way we get away rid of the buzzword
Luis can we let's let's see if we can
come to an a slight agreement on on this
it's equally important to focus on the
problem and the prototyping of the
problem as it is to also care about
identifying problems that are at larger
scales would you would you agree I agree
that you cannot work the beat of
actually trying to prototype the problem
is that you can imagine the problem at
the larger scale as you want and that
first thing you're going to have to do
is bring it down to a table scale yeah
yeah where it actually fits the
resources we have what do you do tackle
these enormous ly about the versions of
the larger problem you may be able to
solve you might even teach you how the
larger problem is much more beautiful
than you first anticipated it would be
yeah and that's what you are so keep
that vision absolutely focus on the
vision okay definitely think big not
baking marking baking problems how I'm
solving yeah right and then let's bring
it down to earth yes I take that problem
you envision figure out how do I
demonstrate to myself that this is not a
fool's errand right just this thing and
there's always a way
in about today to put together things
that you probably did not even know
existed before I gift it to a friend the
other day a book about from O'Reilly
about how to do your own satellite you
know the I love the O'Reilly books and
everything Tim O'Reilly talks about and
yeah but the thing is you may not know
that you can build a satellite at home
yeah there's regulation that you need to
follow definitely there are safety
things that you need to cost tens of
thousands of dollars launch it up into
orbit good cause that but there's also
another book that teaches you how to
launch stuff into orbit against
regulation there's parts you know at the
end of the day if you can put a price
tag to those things and what it would
cost for you to discover it now you know
what you need to do because it's
tangible but if we stay on the scale of
her problem famine or by 2050 no one
will be able to eat will not be one
those are a problem not one problem
there are fifty million what do we do
the solutions yeah and probably there's
something you can start thinking about
today that might actually accelerate the
solution to that big problem and like
you said the journey becomes beautiful
when you start doing what today doing
what tomorrow what you need the journey
becomes very beautiful and we we
frequently think about that and visit it
every day as we are building this
project that we as we're sitting there
and making sure that content gets done
and that of the people are being
impacted it feels really good and
there's this long list of things that
he's gotta do but you know the fact you
you were really good at pointing out
that you still need to have the larger
vision and then system you know what
yeah but let's do it now but what's
critical but what you're are agreeing
about is that there is a gap that gap is
a scale on top you cannot get to the
large scale problem without feeling out
how to survive all the intermediate
levels yeah and that's purpose Caleb I
insist on that because in the in the
literature around right now in the
entrepreneurial literature they talk
about scalable businesses or scalable
ideas ideas are not scalable right
it's not an attribute of the idea it's a
function of what you do next yeah and so
the more you try to figure out how to
as much as what you can about the larger
problem at a smaller scale the more you
learn about the power about the large
problem at the lower cost by winning
you're using the resources very wisely
they're taking the most of your
resources which means that you
anticipate killing propositions if you
want to put about the lore about the
larger problem earlier so the gap that
were discussing about this is a gap of
scale-up and that's what your job is as
an innovator is to bring it up to scale
yeah which means back to one of my pet
peeves which is not about being an
entrepreneur per se right you do this
Bhutan where you want if you want to
create a new company by all means do
that if that's what makes sense to you
but the point is that there's this sense
that you can solve a real world problem
the real world found leads new lives at
a much larger scale you need to start
here and you need to navigate the app
scale until you get there
yeah if a new company is the way to do
it by all means do that you need to do
that inside a company it's not it's a PR
campaign go for PR if it's a policy
issue go for policy right it's not and
then people are putting too much
emphasis on the company and on the big
problem and it's not it's the right
through scales and whatever it takes to
make the problem go away I'm really
happy that we've unpacked the layers to
this and the different pieces to it to
the extent that you've helped me also
understand it better and helped each
other so thank you thank you thank you
yeah yeah okay so that's a bit about the
book let's do a bit as as efficient as
possible let's talk about the i-team's
so MIT innovation teams program so MIT
produces a lot of technology and over
the last ten years now
there's been about 10 new technologies
per semester that have helped that have
come out of of MIT and then then you
take the technology and what do you do
with it
so you put it very nicely so the
business of a university like MIT is to
explore the limits of science
engineering and any other discipline and
produce new knowledge yeah and that the
other day we produce a paper
yeah a demo and so on and that's what
people here would train people to do
when it's super tough but then you know
comes the end of a project now what you
have is knowledge that a new thing is
possible you can do all of them you can
do something new maybe it's cool things
faster maybe it's get lifting cars much
faster or it's something we don't know
what it is we know what it is but we
don't know where it goes and that's the
output of a research university now the
way we take this we say well now we have
evidence that we have a new superpower
like the washing machine is a new put
superpower yeah in hindsight right and
we know that there's one or a family of
problems out there that would go away
because of these new superpower
except that the technology itself is
evidence of the superpower but it's not
the superpower need to figure out what
exactly is it that we need to demand for
that technology we need to figure out
what the actual problem is and then we
need to figure out what kind of an
organization needs to exist or emerge to
kind of oil the entire machinery so the
problem can be solved continuously so
that's what we do we start with the
technology it's the same ideas as in the
book except they might be one of things
we do have is new technologies
yeah and so we unpack it to try to
figure out what the real problem is
there out there that we could solve with
something close to what we got from the
lab but maybe not just what the lab
invented and this is a crucial point so
many technologies you start one way
because it was the easy way to imagine
them and then they have a true value
elsewhere which is what they really have
the value that you almost need to assume
as a starting point that the technology
that you get from a lab is evidence of a
superpower that has not yet been found
or discovered and you need to discover
what is the actual thing that will make
this technology cool and you know
technologies have been developed for car
engines are now being applied in
healthcare because and that's the
hardest thing it's even the problem with
with a lot of interpreters now adays
your idea cannot be a constraint right
so the fact that it was developed in an
energy field doesn't mean it's not
applicable to bio
put it the healthcare so that's what we
do we go through these pastures
which really it's a trans discipline and
with people from all domains of MIT
students from business from engineering
from science from architecture we got
students from Harvard from the Kennedy
School that come and join together in
teams and try to figure out where's a
real world travel it could be soft with
something close to the technology we got
in yes yes and what's the organization
who need to build yes
and then at the end of the semester they
have a set of next steps clean next
stuff to teach them whether they whether
there is something here that can
actually implement and go for it for the
next year year and a half yep because
it'll take about four years or so for
you to actually make something of enough
value to where you can just point people
in the direction they'll go oh I get it
and then right away you know yeah that's
one of the ways in which I start the
class is people students nowadays a lot
of them have heard so much story about
stories of entrepreneurship in hindsight
that there is little teaching about the
dynamics are going place so one of the
first things I do is I tell them well
you know when you have to look at the
statistics and when a company is
actually funded so when they've proven
the value it's about four years so now
that you know it's four years not six
months yeah what did you better do it
right would you rather discover a path
that teaches you how to best use those
four years or would you just go down the
rabbit hole of one idea and that's super
important because you still get four
years so how do you make the best use of
those four years said you truly solve a
problem at the end even if it's not the
one you thought you would be solving it
really it really makes your life more
chunked it makes you realize that if
we're 125 that I'm looking at my life
when I'm 29 and I want to make sure that
what I did every day every month along
the way was every day
slowly innovating on the solute on the
problem that I was solving until 29 when
it becomes much easier to look back and
say that I invested my energy into
solving this problem and it has helped
people around the world and hopefully
helped at scale and that requires people
to also be very good at building
relationships with other smart people
around different industry so that they
can collaborate and work on the project
together
it requires people to be very values
driven and mission driven and not you
know profit driven and consumption
driven because you're gonna you're not
gonna attract as many people that are
that are more grounded into what values
that you want to surround yourself with
and try and build out okay so I think we
can maybe end with just a couple
questions about this because I know this
is this is an amazing thing that you
guys are doing here with i-team's and
you've actually ended up scaling it out
in two different places Singapore and
Russia and Abu Dhabi and stuff that's
amazing that it's now going across the
world because I always talk about this
there's so many people especially young
people across different programs that
are involved in robotics or they're
involved with biotech or whatever that
are just not actually executing the
entrepreneurial side of things the
innovation side of things you get to one
point and then where are the business
people and the marketers and the
salespeople and other designers and
engineers that join you so that way you
can be like oh we can solve this world
problem with that technology that last
step is crucial you're doing that and we
need more of that so I'm happy that
that's scaling now how about we ask a
quick a quick question that we typically
ask our guests on our show the question
is about what we're gonna how do we work
together across the planet because we
have MIT and Harvard out here and
Stanford and Berkeley on the west and
we're you know there's there's now a new
competition over you know all who
invented CRISPR and China is trying to
manipulate genes and they're trying to
advance an AI and Russia's trying to
advance an AI but how do we work
together when you look at Earth from the
moon there's no borders it's just one
rock hall humans live here how do you
envision the next couple of decades with
all these new technologies and how
they're kind of causing a little bit of
wealth and equality and but everybody's
slowly coming up at the same time how do
we kind of work together over time
that's a ginormous question and that and
super interesting so I've been obsessed
about about
you know these inequality for for some
time the seeming raise which we are here
over the things the world is supposed to
get faster except if you drop your phone
you realize it's gotten no more faster
it's just the phone that's but and so
and so how people some people get to
access to the tool to there are some
kinds of things other people don't even
though we were supposed to have more
because of the Internet's of what's
going on and to me and that was one big
motivation to decide when I was one of
what's the pastor skill for my writings
my work it could be just like putting
lots of casting lots of attention on
items and making myself a big name or I
could be sharing something for people
too that that's why I wrote the book the
way I did he's saying you know there's a
way to do this with what you have that's
step one so my skill path is that one
the second path is and it's directly
addressing your question I think there's
an enormous amount of mm inequality
starting with the fact that a lot of the
jobs let's just face it the way we
phrase the washing machine example so
you look at today a lot of the jobs are
being done right now in America our jobs
that are using technologies that to a
large extent are rather old so somehow
we've failed as a society to get all
these super advanced stuff crisper
whatever and and you know a lot of times
we have today to make them usable for
people to experiment and play with them
and why is that important well Microsoft
Altair computer right so what they did
the starting point is them playing with
a hobbyist computer and being able to
code basic inside that HA based computer
and then that's the beginning of
Microsoft playing with technology right
using it for a purpose it's the
beginning of so many things in this
country that it makes you think
everybody spend with apps and we really
spend with the internet but the Internet
is a rather old technology in many ways
right but we're not playing with the
latest technology available though
somehow they've stopped for
dressing instead we are maybe trying to
build too many startups that are for
highly educated people but highly
motivated people without the access to
that education are not getting access to
those things so we're missing we are as
a country we're missing on we'll use
your word creativity of those people
that maybe have not had the access yeah
so the way we solve this is we need to
not just share this to discoveries but
somehow make them usable playable yes so
that you and I could
next time we record something we could
be showing to someone how you can
sequence a genome with household
materials here at that yes it's actually
not impossible but no one knows this and
we need to shift this idea that you need
to get education first and then you'll
be ready hmm you can do both at the same
time you can be educated as you try to
solve a problem you care about you can
acquire that equation better before then
better now than ever anytime before and
she's not democratizing the tools and
putting them more in the hands of people
that have yet to innovate and getting
them inspired to innovate with those
tools as I said paths to solve a problem
that maybe it's not it doesn't it to be
a ginormous world problem yet
maybe a time they have that's how you
get interesting you know you know not
ask me but how did I go from Chemical
Engineer to AI what's that job right he
never asked me so it turns out we had a
computer at home since I was 8 I was
playing with it I had to type in basic
the code for mastermind to the game so I
could play with the computer it give me
20 minutes every day to type the entire
code because we didn't know how to put
the stuff in the computer so I learned
to code that way no problem right he
said it's I just had simple objective
mastermind
I wanted to play mastermind was a cute
thing it was cool my two brothers were
not as interested about that as I was of
hates everyone to their interest but I
could play with it so then I went from
that to code everything use the computer
as my thinking to which is I bought
called
every single method I would learn in
chemical engineering so I would not have
to do them again yeah I learned so much
more Chemical Engineering trying to code
chemical engineering into my computer
that I became
super-good Chemical Engineering and
super good at coding and programming and
using the computer for an objective so
it turns out that that was possible
because I could play with computer yep
so and we get more young we need more
and big-play way it's not just computer
it's not just apps
it's everything out there all these
different kind of technologies you kind
of never had this it planted through my
mind woahh as we were talking was that
it once the technology gets to more
people more children across the world
and then that that process of what do
you do every single day in order to
bring the cost of the technology down to
be able to distribute it to those kids
across the world for them to be able to
easily understand what that technology
is okay so let's call it let's call it
the end of the episode all right Wow so
much fun ladies thank you so much for
coming on to the show and we really
appreciate it I feel like this is only
the beginning of more great
conversations and more great impact
together and so the day we which we
sequence a genome with a strawberry and
we have Lewis's book innovating are
doers of manifesto we'll have the link
in the bio for you to check out and get
that idea get that idea from right here
into what do you need tomorrow in order
to slowly innovate it into the world
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we are here at MIT
Massachusetts Institute of Technology in
Boston it's been a lot of fun and if you
have found the content to be useful give
it a share give it a comment give it a
like subscribe to the channel join us in
our journey and join us on patreon we
greatly need your help to help sustain
us as we continue doing these great
conversations across world and hopefully
inspire you to build the future so
thanks everyone for tuning in Ron thank
you and we'll talk to you soon see ya